previously on fast and furious I said it
before in the last Fast and Furious and
I'll say it again it's amazing how many
highway crimes have absolutely zero
other traffic on the roads it's a
perfect day for a prison break and if I
saw three souped-up cars blasting down
the road while I was transporting
prisoners I'm probably ready my shotgun
maybe even stop the bus and put the odds
over in my favor even though brands
hitting the brakes this bus impact
should still have blown that car off the
road instead the bus flips the car
sticks and Brian lives clearly Brian's
plan for springing Dom includes killing
Dom never mind any of the non main
character prisoners that died in this
horrific crash has been accounted for
except for one Dominic Toretto accounted
for did anyone die this is the most
remarkable bus crash ever this news
broadcast montage never once mentions
fatalities which is what the news lives
for with Laredo and O'Conner are now is
anyone's guess with the terrible copping
we saw in the last film couldn't they be
in LA having beers at the Toretto home
without law enforcement knowing about it
Rio porn yep this pit is back how's it
feel feels great wait a minute what the
are you talking about
be on the other side of a wanted poster
well you can't really be on any other
side of a wanted poster can you you can
pick any side and you'll still be on a
wanted poster
there's no good side this is me I'm
putting the baby to bed scene couldn't
possibly be foreshadowing her own
pregnancy could it le sabe Oh ma'am I
cannot believe it it looks like you both
could use the payday sure they're poor
so naturally the only possible action to
take is Grand Theft Auto I guess it's a
good thing these DEA agents and anyone
else on this train who are Americans are
super unobservant what with Brian and
Mia's faces plastered everywhere after
the prison break this stupid heist would
never work the chances of anyone seeing
your crew alongside the train are much
too high there are many passengers
facing the back side of the Train
looking out windows and would easily see
you these guys fall on their faces to
avoid being killed by the dangerous
sheet of death they ripped off the train
but in the next shot they're standing
tall looking like conquering heroes as
if half the crew didn't almost die from
their own stupidity LaVonda forty
wouldn't the plan be pre-arranged
because he says this and isn't careful
enough to think Dom speaks Portuguese
Dom gets suspicious and the whole plan
blows up in their faces for no reason
and the method of car theft virtually
guarantees massive damage to all three
vehicles even though the movie doesn't
think so this car obviously has
something in it that these guys want but
why didn't they call some sort of
criminal dibs on it before this round or
even started they could have said look
you can have any
on that train to the gt40 is off-limits
church records wave Markel they got to
Rio yesterday and had no idea until you
stepped on this train car you were even
coming
what prearranged meeting point could you
possibly have under this scenario I
didn't me at least pretend to be going
the right way until the dickheads on the
train we're out of sight ah Dom throws
this guy to the floor rather than
outside making this fight to the death
harder for himself this movie wants to
have everything both ways windows don't
matter until they do you movie yeah
catch up to the gt40 which has a huge
head start in this clunky ass vehicle
thing comes out of nowhere to impair all
the stuff car cops here to protect the
train don't have an access card to the
train doors
this guy picks up a crowbar but he hits
down in the back instead of launching it
into his head or neck and causing major
damage
maybe this weird vehicle has a blowtorch
on it maybe but for this guy getting
kicked and driving the vehicle to be
able to reach back and turn on the
blowtorch to use as a weapon ya know why
haven't you thrown him off the train yet
Bryan survives this also wow that is a
lot of dead people for our heroes to
steal a few cars am i right this train
is this clean close to the bridge when
Brian tells Dom about it but somehow
this will take more than one minute of
movie time to actually get there car
stunts that aren't possible or one thing
humans living through like this over and
over that's simple how are there any bad
guys waiting for them anywhere near this
water even if the dude back on the train
radioed it in how are their readily
available assholes on standby under the
train bridge alright I'm going to leave
you in an easily escapable situation
with my worst henchmen on guard I'll see
you later in the movie walmart cuffs
random guy with gun decides the guns
don't have long-range capabilities and
points it as close as possible to Dom's
hit it's easy to look badass when these
bad guys are idiots where's Vince that's
a good question did Vince even know
there was a change in plans
he was the first dude off the train and
it was only when Dom realized that the
other dudes one of the gt40 that had
changed the plan something I was tired
but I'm sure to be interrupted before I
can say it that was your job the problem
with this movie is that we don't know
what the original plan was it was
supposed to do one or if the plan got
changed before they got on the train
they never explained five hundred years
ago Portuguese and the Spanish came here
this business deal will require the
history of Brazil in order to move
forward
almost were shot in the Caesar
why did the bad guys bother with his
huge operation to steal cars if all they
wanted was a chip they could have hired
a pickpocket and an auto mechanic to
board the train and find the chip and
pulled this job off with way less
problems I thought the job was for the
cars this whole movie is predicated on
the fact that Dom overheard Zizi say he
wanted the gt40 and got suspicious
because of the suspicion it leads to a
chain of events that didn't need to
happen
why did Don care if they stole that
particular car or not why does he care
if it has a chip in it was he worried
that once the bad guys took the gt40
they were gonna get screwed over or even
killed we don't know nothing is implied
or explicitly stated well I want a list
of every place within 50 miles bus crash
prisoner escape train accident Marshall
barking out orders this movie is the
fugitive the ground rolls into a
hardpack and we lost that track too
no necessarily that road heads up
through the hills into the favelas it's
old dirt a mile from where you were okay
but don't tracks become really hard to
find after a day or so because of people
driving over the dirt and walking over
it real porn to fast furious fellows you
I didn't see one damn dirt road on their
way up here
lots of cobbled streets and concrete and
whatever you want to call it but
certainly not something so easy to find
tracks that they went straight to the
hideout 100 million plus in cash houses
how it keeps it off the grid
wait what he's trying to keep the
location of cash houses off the grid and
has commissioned a custom computer chip
and software interface that is then
plugged into regular devices that puts
it on the grid just use ink and
paper it does not get any more off the
grid than that
once again assholes don't bother finding
the other potential exits and guarding
them before going in for an attack all
right how did he miss two full minutes
of discount Bourne Ultimatum this is the
third time someone's pulled a gun on Dom
this close to him DSS guys shoot
everyone except one of the main bad guys
let's go by the way I'm pregnant now
forget it Brian and Mia survived this
Dom did not lose this freaking necklace
last time we saw him it was perfectly
fine around his neck and no danger of
slipping off just like that
well maybe I did just jump off of a roof
into another roof a minute ago but last
time I checked pregnant all these guys
are is names on a list that come up we
take them down not a phone call more not
a bullet less whatever that means
I know you mean we don't ask any further
questions but that's just silly anything
else yeah we tracked the owner off the
vehicle ID which we should have already
known considering they were in the DDA's
possession just a day ago this is the I
don't know about my dad
sudden character backstory is sudden and
cliche and considering the pending baby
super-convenient its sudden being in
cliche into one last job we're gonna
take all of raises money here's the Fast
and Furious franchise officially turning
the keys over to Ocean's eleven we're
gonna take all of raises money every
dime of it and disappear why not just
disappear wouldn't it be easier and
safer I guess you might need money to
start a new life somewhere but Jesus if
you're that addicted to stealing I think
I'm gonna have to start considering you
the bad guys of this series oh I see
you're going to take the three or four
weeks to debate on the right guys then
contact them then wait for them to get
to Rio and then take down the crime boss
you have no real beef with whatsoever Oh
Tyreese dragged this movie into this
didn't eat also how are you gonna
coordinate and communicate with all
these people while the rock is actively
seeking you out and what none of your
former associates are being bugged or
followed or anything that's his legs
baby girl
what time do they open Jesus even we
wouldn't say some like this but
movie gets away with it because I have
no idea also this is a convergence of
all the franchises now we have 2 fast 2
furious and Tokyo Drift thrown into this
mess eventually they'll all be joined by
the Expendables
because we got a job instead of escaping
Rio we've decided to target the biggest
crime boss in the city and steal his
money
we think that's justifiable because one
time we tried to steal a car that he
wanted to steal and he chained us up for
a bit before we escaped don't ask any
questions just listen this is what
constitutes security at this place guy
owns the whole city and he can afford
security cameras on the outside of the
building to make sure something like
this doesn't happen meanwhile he has for
on the naked counting chicks in vagi
donut Gaza deliver random reyes soldier
plays the pronoun game with Reyes so
that he has to ask who the hell they are
a little by sus casas there's no reason
to simply up the security or have more
guy
earning it nope just put it all in one
place why not he's moving into a police
station he's got some serious brass in
his pocket kind of makes you wonder why
he bothers with ten different secret
money houses if he can just openly stash
his cash in the police station
this just went from Mission Impossible
to Mission and freakish sanity yeah are
in that paycheck tyrese enhancer zoom
and enhance cliche the faces are covert
run it through fr-s facial recognition
software but you just said their faces
were covered the beauty of public
offices public records even in Brazil it
took the u.s. until the Freedom of
Information Act for motion to become
public and even then I'm not sure police
station blueprints count says Caucasian
ice a tan no it's Han Jesus Christ so of
course the box that Tyrese brings in
goes right in the room with a safe
because whenever you make a stupid plan
with one percent chance of it working it
works if you had a camera robot
in this box then why even go to the
trouble of trying so hard or at all to
get them to let you into the evidence
room physically was it just to create
some kind of relief also these
cops on the take from billionaire crime
lord don't have cameras in the evidence
room that contains his vault of billions
in order to see this RC car movie
depicts exactly what it's like watching
these movies okama let's go get some
cars okay but just as a reminder this is
all just for revenge you're doing all
this to steal from a dude that with you
one time over a car that you were in the
act of stealing thinest premise ever
yes let's collectively enjoy the hot
asses of girls who aren't my sister that
you knocked up what on the street is a
lot of people looking for you too and
yet but you didn't think we've
recognized you after the last movie no
actually we assumed bran was
unrecognizable to the street racing
world since they let him back in
undercover after he put over everyone in
the first film but whatever just get to
the race already clausal called
you want to come and get it if the feds
ID'd his car from a traffic cam how's
Tom able to drive it anywhere in the
city without being found aren't they
searching for it via satellite every 15
minutes where'd you get that from
Papa smart okay Tyrese We Need to Talk
I'm beginning to wonder if you even
deserve to keep earning paychecks please
call me the highly wanted DOM and Brian
being tracked by the entire Rio police
force and the DSS can not only find a
space where no one can find them it's
also big enough to simulate the police
station they're about to rob know what
while the feds are actively hunting you
with satellites you can have a ginormous
safe delivered to some warehouse without
anyone anywhere getting suspicious
there's still another problem palm scan
which I somehow didn't know to
despite my zoomed in RC car camera view
of the thing more real porn fast v
gangbang hobbs specifically told his
crew he wanted them to follow Reyes to
the point of knowing how much he shakes
it when he goes to the bathroom nobody
from the DEA here today ah not only did
you stop for a change of clothes you
also made sure to choose fingerprint
friendly material nice Saudis is like
slap that ass or did he like grab and
hold on to it I know you're kidding but
no it was like he was actually trying to
help you rob him with the way he touched
her ass guys guys guys we have a problem
the whole team just got burnt you mean
just now that's convenient
since we saw all of you getting
investigated 17 minutes ago in movie
time which is like an eternity in real
time this did not just happen
despite the movie wishing it did
problems right we need to get some
fresher you people did not speak this
vaguely you just wanted the audience to
wonder what he meant we've got a hit 7
charge of the how did this thing
not work properly the night of the
street race earlier you turn around and
put your hands behind your back oh
thanks so seems like he could have
waited this out and got DOM and Brian
later when there weren't so many people
around but that's just me this is brah
zu something that Hobbs local agent
Alena should have been able to tell him
but seeing how Hobbs talks to her she
probably thinks she's a 1950s housewife
at this point yes I don't know if you
realize it but this is the moment when
the stars of the pacifier and tooth
fairy finally squared off the only
reason this necklace bolt is in the
movie is so that Dom could have another
I miss Letty scene with a woman who
misses her husband and they really shot
for the moon on their helicopter shot
budget for this movie didn't they anyway
we're gonna beat the cameras is with
invisible cars and I know just where to
get them if it's so easy to steal cop
cars why didn't they do this in the
first place
meanwhile security at a souped up cop
car Mecca is extremely lacks they
probably fed the dog steaks slip the
guard sleeping pills in their coffee and
found a way for security cameras to not
exist next to light these idiots are
actually going to drag race stolen
police cars in Rio right now also isn't
this a pretty stupid race aren't
on four of these cars identical should
this end in a four-way tie welcome to a
world with zero rules ladies and
gentlemen my brain has officially ended
itself watching the scene I mean does
Rio have a strict nobody out past 9 p.m.
curfew or something here's me unwanted
by Brazilian and US forces openly
shopping in the public market because
screw you we'll do what we want it's
pretty hard they tracked yo I see Mia is
being followed by the drug lord soldiers
not the cops and by Vince conveniently
placed his guy
waiting for me at the market and that's
all they were doing just sitting there
waiting until Vince showed up to save me
I don't know why they haven't started
tracking you two kids yet but enough of
that events Dom agrees to let Vince take
part in the heist which is fine a nice
family moment but doesn't that mean the
entire plan has to be reworked to
include him or at least he needs to
spend all night studying to learn his
role family is one thing but this is
sort of careless if you ask me we're
less than 24 hours from the biggest
celebration of our life movie that is
over two hours long has time for a lone
premature celebration scene hey Wei Wei
hold on a sec so did he just smack the
ass or did he grab uh-huh that's an
inside joke that we don't know the
context for but hilarious nonetheless
took me a while to find that tracking
chip which had little or no bearing on
the story also this doesn't explain how
they all of a sudden know where the
hideout is despite the fact that they
should have found it way earlier in this
movie super important cop mission goes
out the window for mono e mono
fisticuffs how the did they know
the DSS people were going to drive
through here also does this movie know
that it just stole a page from clear and
present danger a movie where the villain
was played by the exact same actor who
plays the villain in this movie look at
many poor people in this poor part of
Rio having satellite television and how
much does it cost therefore American
only DISH Network this ambush rescue
seems to have a high likelihood of
killing the people being rescued movies
long string of uncon secuence --is
continues but I'm sorry I fell asleep
therefore what's going on then we would
somehow all this guy's men died in the
shootout but he lived which is probably
only because he already had lines in the
movie or something Vince got shot and
the movie actually expects me to feel
bad about it hideout eulogy meanwhile
all the other good guys are halfway
through the police station heist right I
mean how much time has passed since they
tore out of here suicide mission that's
a man over there on the table yeah but
the original plan didn't even include
him right amen
you saved my life so the law no longer
matters and in fact I'm going to break
that law with you Jen just go sneaking
around anymore
you weren't even sneaking around at all
you were brazenly shopping in street
markets and participating in street
races well it's a good thing that all of
these police officers are bad guys and
none of them are actually just innocent
men protecting the police station
because this might seem rash all that
nonsense about hairpin turns and fast
cars avoiding video cameras and the
movie is going to ultimately have them
steal the entire safe through tow cable
brute force because if you're still
watching you certainly don't care why
wasn't the original plan to get an
armored vehicle and do this a couple of
fast muscle cars can just pull how much
was it ludicrous 10 tons of
top-of-the-line security out of a
wall can't we agree at this point that
this is where the cars would flip over
from you know all the physics I'd
complain about the terrible aim but I'm
more concerned about the zillion tonne
safe being dragged by two american-made
cars well the plans working you guys
have every corrupt cop in Rio on your
tail how do you know that all of them
are corrupt some of these guys I'm wrong
might just be doing their job DOM and
Brian very likely killed lots of people
and caused millions of dollars of
property damage because they're trying
to get back at a guy who just wanted a
computer chip from a car seized by the
DEA I'm still trying to figure out if
this plot is even real
they're now pulling a safe that is
crashing through a storm I wish this
safe were magnetized so we could watch
with hyeri as they pull all the cars and
boats planes jewelry and basically all
that from spider-man
- now Dom's car is pulling the same and
the other car by itself because there's
a great disturbance in the force not the
star wars force mind you the force
described by Isaac Newton is disturbed
Brian laughs because he doesn't yet
realize how many innocent people he's
killed during the scene anytime this
cadre of police officers chasing Brian
and Dom on a shoot for the tires is okay
with me why are they still firing guns
anyway when that's been proven and
effective in this movie Weiss is the
righteous tracer please please get
another check to mr. Gibson
Wow that's like murder how has no one in
this movie said the word Hemi yet it was
always the plan
take care I was it always the planet
when the original plan before the rock
came on board did not involve you
dragging the safe out of town like this
also hero sacrifices himself to save the
others cliche I guess this is
entertaining for many people with
nothing being grounded in any realism at
all we just accept that Dobbs pulling a
ten-ton safe with this one car right now
maneuvering in such a way that he can
guide the safe anywhere he wants it to
go I think this movie is basically just
telling you relax it's only a movie
which I hate now the safe and all its
weight in momentum can suddenly pull
downs car in another direction I guess
it was waiting for the movie to allow it
to do what it should have done way back
at the police station guy about to shoot
another guy get shot at the last second
by some surprised ex machina asshole
cliche how of a mess beyond all the
damage to Rio and all the likely
fatalities were now left with a Rio that
currently has no living Police
Department to put the kid from die hard
with a vengeance it's Christmas you
could steal City Hall come tomorrow I
will find Joe he's already allowed them
to do this crash the safe through Rio
thing he doesn't owe them anything
anymore
his character in no way benefits from
letting them have 24 hours to go play
hide and seek Hobbes lets these guys go
and doesn't check the save until after
they're gone second window a 10-second
window to unload a 10 ton safe into a
garbage truck and switch it with another
10 ton safe before anyone notices and
despite your considerable driving skills
something you've never practiced in your
life is going to go off without a hitch
and fool everyone
so you somehow planned this bull
discreetly in a matter of minutes after
the rock joined the cause which is
complete cop that tried to bust
our heroes ends up respecting them so
much he laughs upon learning they got
away with the cliche I know they've been
given 24 hours but I can't believe
Hobbes doesn't raid this hideout again
part of the deal was that they couldn't
take the money and he knows they
switched the safes but he decides to lay
off for some stupid reason let that be a
lesson to you kids stealing is totally
ok as long as you steal from a bigger
head than yourself unearned romantic
coupling oh they got together because
their significant others died didn't
think but they have so much in common
beyond the tragic deaths that tied them
together you need to look at that
the irony is we are looking at that but
Hobbes can't look at that because she's
turned the wrong way well well let he's
not dead I'm sure there will be some
terrific explanation for this
considering that dude Phoenix for the
last movie asked Tom Murphy
that Mossad it was back probably just a
twin sister or something
poor long loss previously unknown and
dead twin sister give me the damn
veggies
I once caught a fish this day frost
brewed Coors Light world's most
refreshing beer I hear your sister is
very beautiful and your wife moan like a
whore
when they ravaged her again and again
use a hard-target search of every gas
station residence warehouse farmhouse
henhouse out this guy's he's Old
Testament blood bullets wrath of God
fire and brimstone coming down from the
skies rivers and seas boiling twenty
years of darkness earthquakes volcanoes
the dead rising from the grave human
sacrifice dogs and cats living together
Mac you realize we're talking about
going up against the most powerful guy
in all a real yes we are
then we're gonna need a team you think
we need one more all right we'll get one
more hey everybody if you have an
interest in a book about disabled
superhero kids I just happened to write
something like that and you can now
pre-order the eBook version the
audiobook is coming soon as well